Це моя Мій вклад в цю перемогу в цю яку
Ми віримо я не можу залишатися осторонь
хоча мені вже стільки років щоб можна
було б відпочити
безпосередньо туди в окопи воювать то
допомагай чи грошима чи волонтер Я хочу
своєю
своєю маленькою роботою ну закрию ході
одного солдата і одну хоть машину Хоч
якийсь кусочок но вижили попри свій
поважний вік Ці жінки вірять що
дочекаються Перемоги України і як
волонтерки чи можуть підтримують ЗСУ
історію цих українських пенсіонерок
надихають
у свої 78 панітая з ворзеля на Київщині
підтримує українське військо спершу
робила це як партизанка під час окупації
рідного селища Тепер як волонтерка
[музика]
2 війна сволоти 9-го приїхали
11-13 одиниць техніки те що
бачила ти і записувала от їдуть звідти
колона то я їх записую Що там
стільки-тотанг скільки БМП бензовоз
бортова машина де там на резиновому ходу
на тому на тому поїхали куди ви в яку
сторону в який час
під час окупації ворзеля пенсіонерка
щодня записувала дані про техніку росіян
і потім передавала їх ЗСУ через
волонтерів також вона віддала майже всю
хату під склад гуманітарки і годувала
людей в окупації і після неї
котлетки
на мангалі
[музика]
багато людей хто не хотів брати на себя
відповідальность Ну ми зверталися до
місцевих людей ну можемо у вас залишити
якісь продукти і так далі вони казали ні
сейчас ви і не приїжджайте его після вас
приїжджають сюда танки
після звільнення Київщини пам’ятає
почала збирати гроші для ЗСУ з власної
пенсії та коли назбирала 10 тисяч
гривень її обікрали про історію бабусі
волонтерки розповіли у соцмережах і за
лічені дні в Україні та Литві зібрали
всю суму і передали пенсіонерці пані Тая
віддала кошти військовим на купівлю
Дронів
Слава Україні Хай
вам напоміч буде і на перемогу БПЛА уже
на фронті звітують волонтери снаряд від
баби таї от
туди їм дорога я б в себе разом з
кремлем
має намір продовжувати допомагати ЗСУ аж
до перемоги А ще Як волонтерка вчить
усіх охочих української мови
безпосередньо
тут чи волонтер
А це 83-річна Романа маліщук з Миколаєва
Вона вирішила допомагати ЗСУ що рік тому
проте волонтерські організації спершу
відмовляли пенсіонерці через вік
я кругом шукала таку організацію
Ну мені всі відказували тому що як
спитають скільки років я ми вам
передзвоне і так не переживали а тут мер
нас семкевич дав об'яву ось це з цим
номером телефона і я по цьому номеру
телефона сюда прийшла і тут мене не
спитали скільки мені років а сказали
будь ласка приходьте ми для вас знайдемо
роботу
відтоді пані Романа Майже щодня працює у
цьому волонтерському центрі літня жінка
виготовляє сітки для українських
військових
матеріальна я не можу нічим помогти бо я
давно вже пенсіонерка і
от я в тому ж найшла цю організацію щоб
допомогти хоч чим я хочу своєю
своєю маленькою роботою ну закрию ході
одного солдата і одну хоть машину Хоч
якийсь кусочок но вижили той хто буде
закритий нашими сітками я роблю одне і
те саме ми Ріжемо матеріали на Отакі
полоски
[музика]
а з великих з цих полосок якщо вони
маленькі Ми їх зв'язуємо зшиваємо і тоді
плетуть сітки
у Миколаєві у жінки не залишилося рідних
пенсіонерка живе сама тож Волонтерський
центр став для неї другим домом тут вона
відсвяткувала і свій 83 день народження
[музика]
який цвіти
і даже депутат приїхав поздоровити
то було для мене трудно пережити тому що
я ніколи не попадала в такі обставини
щоб ви мене хто то честював
все в житті буває і це треба пережити
пані роману вважають однією з
найпродуктивніших волонтерок
83-річна пенсіонерка працює на рівні з
молодшими на 20-30 років колегами
допомагати ЗСУ жінка планує аж до
закінчення війни нині найбільша мрія
пенсіонерки дожити до перемоги України
як не працювала Я була настільки хвора
що мені не хотілося скривати вставати
Ну як я сюди прийшла з першого дня в
мене Д енергія взялася настільки енергії
що в мене напевно в лід 40 вже не було
такої енергії як зараз зараз я на
ентузіазмідержуйся правда буває що тиск
підскакує
вік вже нічого не зробиш Ну я стараюся
триматися і буду триматися до останнього
дня війни
Перемоги обов'язково дочекаюся
відома українська акторка Галина
Яблонська вдруге за життя бачить війну
нині у свої 95 вона активно займається
волонтерством регулярно відвідує
поранених захисників у шпиталях і
влаштовує творчий виступи для військових
Це моя
Мій вклад в цю перемогу в цю яку Ми
віримо я не можу залишатися осторонь
хоча мені вже стільки років щоб можна
було б відпочити а я собі не можу цього
дозволити тому що я знаю що після моїх
виступів мені дякують мене якось знаєте
я відчуваю що те що я роблю Вона
потрібна Вона підтримує воно надає людям
теж якогось
більшої віри у роки Другої світової
війни пані Галина була підлітком акторка
й досі пам'ятає жахіття тієї війни але
каже що теперішні злочини росіян ще
страшніші школи були знищені але був
сільськогосподарський технікум готували
свою робочу силу вони не забирали на
роботу в Німеччину але такої руйнації як
зараз І це ви знаєте ще одне
підтвердження тому що
оцей путляр
Путін Він знає що він тут не буде
господарем бо якби він це знав він би
такого не руйнував би під час Другої
Світової акторка ледь не загинула коли
мені хазяйка сказала що піде
бомбосховище Я думаю що буде тебе мозку
чи є така маленька Що ти от бомби саме
на мене І саме на мене вона впала мене
засипала і я вже прощала з цим всім тому
що Чую хтось по мені ходить ще по тому
завалу тут хто то есть і вони почали
мене розріпати я розлюблю руки я потім
руки своїми руками поздирала собі нігті
щоб вдихнути Галина Яблонська працювала
з легендарним акторами режисером гнатом
Юрою відома акторка виступає на сцені
майже 90 років нині найбільша мрія пані
Галини перемога України
виживе і стане законодавцем в Україну
будуть приїздити в Україні будуть шукати
тому що таких пісень як у нас Ніде в
світі нема таких вишиванок таких
костюмів Я думаю що
Європа навіть прийде до нас буде вчитися
нашому
нашій нашому вмінню любити цей світ